this video contains images of a
preserved severed human toe just worn
there's not really much I can say here
I'm in Dawson City which is an old
mining town and the Yukon Territory what
a Klondike in Yukon rivers meet and this
this is a cocktail with a severed human
toe in it
the sourdough cocktail it's real simple
straight shot of liquor at least 40% and
you drop a human toe into it it all
started way back in prohibition area two
brothers running alcohol up into Alaska
they thought the police were on the
trail so one of the brothers stepped
through some water got frostbite on his
toe the other brother took an axe hacked
off the toe they left it in a jar of
their alcohol out in a cabin in the
woods years later cabin dick Stevenson
bought this cabin was emptying out and
he found this jar with a toe in it
thought it'd be hilarious to bring it to
the bar and do some drinks with it with
his friends and sour toe cocktail was
born our toes we received from donors
mostly anonymous but yeah we actually
have a gentleman over in the UK right
now who ran the Yukon ultramarathon over
the winter got frostbite and decided you
know what might as well put these frost
bit and remove toes to good use so we're
having somebody picked them up in June
and hopefully you know he can come back
here someday and you know do his own
toes and a sour toe cocktail Terri Lee
is our current sourdough master former
ferry boat captain so he's got his title
captain they're fun guy loves his toes I
served four nights a week I've been
doing this for five years and I've seen
all kinds of people this toe is a
hammertoe
which was deformed it so had to be
removed whoo it was removed from I don't
know person is probably still alive but
for most cases his people is good that's
total number 13 the other toes you know
one was lost a couple of wrists stole
and returned some just get used up v or
swallowed one on purpose I didn't even
want to talk about that guy they've gone
through quite a life full disclosure I
don't drink alcohol is a little bit of
special dispensation here I still have
the shot of liquor and the toast all
going in it but I'm pouring off the
liquor and putting the toe in some
ginger ale instead
I'm sure this within the rules it's safe
I mean the health inspector gives us the
okay to do it it used to be that it
could be done in anything from milk to
pop - champagne - beer but in more
recent years we've were sticking to
straight alcohol that's 40% or higher
and that's sort of our way of appeasing
the health inspector and and making sure
this this can continue on now that
summer is coming on you can get pretty
busy we can do upwards of 50 60 70
tonight up to now if we are at 70 7888
but that's since June 11th 1995 this toe
started in 1973 so the number could be
could be a hundred thousand I could wax
philosophical for a while on how this
isn't actually this disgusting it's just
like having a bit of beef jerky in there
that's being used as a as a garnish I'm
actually the only the beef jerky would
be much less likely to consent than the
owner of the toe but I know you're here
for let's do it yes are you ready I'm
ready
you better be be warned toll must not
end at the mouth or be bitten chewed or
god forbid swallow ders at $2,500 five
and so in light of the above you can
drink it fast you can drink it slow but
your lips must touch this gnarly toe yes
you lips no teeth no tongue no tonsils
he goes alright pour out Mallika pour
out the toe Cheers
and there it is
this is the certification of your fall
user thank you very much
you